mandine n'est pour l'instant qu'un
prénom mais c'est déjà la petite fille
plus célèbre de france ce soir 43 heures
après sa naissance
vous savez presque tout d'elle 3 kg 4 51
cm et surtout son extraordinaire
conception dans une éprouvette 1982 la
france voit pour la première fois le
visage de la procréation médicalement
assistée
trente cinq ans plus tard certaines
femmes célibataires ou certains couples
de femmes revendique-t-elle aussi le
droit à la pma le comité consultatif
national d'éthique doit rendre son avis
ces jours ci en 1982 aucun texte aucune
loi c'est les médecins eux-mêmes qui
réclamaient des cadres afin de continuer
la recherche de façon éthique
le docteur frydman père scientifique de
la petite amandine l'expliquait sur un
plateau télé et c'est parce que
justement nous pensons que nous ne
sommes pas habilités à prendre seule
cette décision et que parce qu'il faut
qu'il y ait une confrontation de
plusieurs points de vue que d'emblée
avant que cette situation se prolonge ou
s'accentue que nous posons le problème
et en particulier celui des comités
éthiques je crois sur lequel nous
reviendrons en 1983 françois mitterrand
créé par décret le premier comité
consultatif national d'éthique à l'ordre
du jour la procréation médicalement
assistée
la science d'aujourd'hui en l'homme de
vitesse à tel point que certains
chercheurs eux mêmes ont appelé en
conscience un arrêt de la recherche
dès lors qu'elles touchent aux
manipulations de lui même il faudra
encore attendre dix ans il lois de
bioéthique pour statuer
la procréation médicalement assistée
s'adresse à des couples hétérosexuels
ensemble depuis minimum 2 ans est en âge
de procréer mais lorsque françois
hollande arrive au pouvoir
il promet le mariage pour tous et
l'ouverture de la pma aux couples de
femmes montée de boucliers dans la rue
procréation médicalement assistée
théorie du genre
les anti mariage homo vivre à nouveau
printemps
on a tous été créés et naturellement il
ya aucune raison que ça change
face à cette mobilisation le
gouvernement rétropédale et donne en
2013 ce délicat dossier au fameux comité
d'éthique qui tarde à rendre son avis
pour certaines la solution est donc à
l'étranger en espagne ou en belgique où
la pma est autorisée mais si ça patine
au niveau éthique
la cour de cassation elle est favorable
depuis 2014 à l'adoption de l'enfant par
la compagne de la mère biologique marine
va pouvoir adopter la fille de sa
compagne lysian conçu par procréation
médicalement assistée à l'étranger on
est conforté dans notre bon droit aussi
la légitimité d'être parent d'avoir
envie de fonder des familles en sécurité
et être serein pour la suite
une situation ubuesque dénoncé il ya un
an par 130 médecins dont rené frydman
ces grands spécialistes ont avoué avoir
aidé des couples de femmes à avoir des
enfants en france
une situation qui est donc encore
illégal il risque en théorie cinq ans de
prison et 75000 euros d'amande
[Musique]